can you imagine i mean my hair turned in
black
a few hours before one of the most
important performances of my life i was
freaking out so what did you do so we
had to like dye it again use 40 peroxide
water my my scalp got really irritated
and a lot of stuff happen afterwards
[Music]
hi i'm shakira and this is my glamour
unfiltered
when you talk about the planet
it's it's
we're facing so many issues that are so
urgent
i don't have the luxury i don't think
that any of us has the luxury to to say
oh no i'm not going to participate in
that cause because i think that
everyone who lives in this planet is
directly affected by all those issues
[Music]
it's been amazing to work
with him on this it's
i love to see someone like him so
committed and so determined
and
so passionate as well i feel very humble
to
to be a part of a project that is really
trying to encourage people all over the
world to do their best to really come up
with the most innovative ideas to
preserve this planet to clean our air to
revive our oceans things that are just
so urgent and he's one of the
people who who are really aware of this
in the and the
and how imminent and how how necessary
it is that we all work together that we
all collaborate and and cooperate as a
collective
in order to to really achieve results
[Music]
my children have actually been the
reason why i wanted to
sign on for this
seeing them so worried so concerned
about the planet and and how they can
make this a better place
um it's
has been so inspiring to me as a mother
i as a parent i want to make sure that
they they will live in a world that that
would be better than the one i grew up
in the young people of today
this generation
will be the generation that will affect
change
[Music]
it's not impossible it's doable and
but
it needs the commitment we need the
commitment of governments private sector
civil society in general teachers
students everyone
we we all have to really discuss this
and create a debate in society
that makes us all aware
of what's at stake
my mother empowered me as a woman she
made me believe that i was able
to achieve anything in life
being a parent
and being a mother knowing that my kids
need me that i would do anything for
them
sometimes i feel that i'm literally
juggling everything you know motherhood
being
a woman being a celebrity an artist
always feeling that one of the apples is
about to drop
but you know i managed to do it like
every other woman in the world who's
also
working
and
raising children and
i mean it's something that only women
can do you know we can do it all we can
multitask something a man can do you
know they can't chew gum and cross the
street
not at the same time
maybe but i really didn't focus on that
i think i i i
suffered more of other kinds of
prejudice like being colombian i
remember when i first you know when i
when
when i had my first uh big break
in music um
outside columbia
uh there were many you know double
entendre comments about you know
what it meant to be colombian and they
usually associate it with you know drug
trafficking and all of that and it's
like there were always the jokes you
know
yeah it was uncomfortable at times um
and i knew that there was a lot to be
done and knew that i had to prove a lot
of people wrong and i knew that i had to
show the world
um
a more truthful side of
my country
oh yeah all the time sometimes i i
project this like
this this image of confidence but in
in reality i'm very very insecure and
like
i feel like i have the duality you know
it's it's weird because sometimes i feel
really really empowered that i can do it
all but it never happens without me
going through a process of self-doubt
like i can never achieve anything
anything in life not not as a not as a
mother not as a singer not as a
philanthropist without
thinking things not twice
a thousand times
yeah and going through this labyrinth in
my mind
about what i can and i can't do
[Music]
i think that i've been pursuing
making a song like this for a while
already and when
you know when it started to happen i was
like yeah i instantly recognized that
this was what i was looking for and and
it just happened organically
so quickly we were writing that song and
you know in less than a few hours and
and after a couple of days we had it all
produced and and almost done and and i
wanted to release it
as fast as possible
for a person who
is
a little bit of a control freak like i
am
surfing is actually very very
therapeutic because i feel
that
you know when you're out there in in the
ocean waiting for for a wave you can't
control anything
about that environment you can't control
the waves you can control
um
the the weather the temperature just
have to go with the flow and and adapt i
actually never am ever in my wildest
dreams imagined that i would like
something
like that but but i'm just so addictive
and
and once i started surfing
i just i couldn't stop i couldn't stop
um i just had to do it
every time
every time i could and
and whenever i go in the water and i
surf i spend days dreaming about that
like i just dream about waves every
night and every night it's just
something that gets
deep in my
under my skin right now and i just i
just i just have to do it
[Music]
yeah you tend to forget about it but yes
i am a wag in fact
i'm very proud to say so
i don't know my hair has gone through so
much so much it's it's the is the
biggest source of suffering in my life
like
i cannot even begin to tell you the
things that happen to me only happen to
me and my hair like even like my my hair
stylist and have had a few they're like
oh your hair has a mind on its own your
hair does things like if i only told you
what happened to me like one night
before the the super bowl i was dying my
hair with the exact same hair dye that i
used every time
and that day that night my hair decided
to turn black
so it just went black it was my birthday
it was like
almost midnight and of course the next
day i had to be
up and ready and perfect and fresh and i
had my beauty sleep and all that but no
of course that didn't happen to me
because it had there had to be some kind
of drama especially before the super
bowl my head just reacts on you know in
different ways every time just it has a
mind on its own
you